Ngoài Hienu, một thân tư tại chủ sợ chính phủ.
Hú tưởng chính phủ và mấy chính đạo tiếp ông Dú Sê A数 An Sơn
Đại dữ cua tại Việt Nam để cho đổi về các biển pháp thuộc đầy quan hệ đối tác chính lực.
Cung nhưng hợp tác bảo ra bản định năng lượng giữa hành lực.
Tại cuộc biết, nhất lại kết quả cuộc biển đàn thành công với thu tưởng cua đồ tháng 3 của qua.
Hú tưởng chính phủ và mấy chính đề gỳ 2 bên của hợp chắc chẽ để cụ thể hoa hơn các người dụng đả thung nhất.
Năng biệt là việc bảo đàn ăn toàn cho công dân Việt Nam tại cua hết.
Hãy bảo trình khai kế hoa hành động dẻ đoạn hành hành hình của trong hệ sáu Hành hình của chá bá mưa
theo gướng đa giản hoa các định vực hát.
Nhanh dừng này, thu tưởng chính chọng chuyển lời tham hỏi của Tụi Mítu Thor Lâm
và các linh đạo thức cao Việt Nam tới quốc buân và lãnh đạo phü et.
Mời thu tưởng cua, tham chính thức Việt Nam trong năm hành hành hình của trong hệ sáu.
Chức chính diễn biến vức tạo tại Trung Đông.
Thủ đường bây giờ quan hãy về những tác động thư cơm đến anh đến và sự ổn định của thịt chất ký tế,
đang lượng tăng cầu,
nhưng mạnh lập trường như quán của Việt Nam là các chiến chấp phải được dài quyết bằng biển pháp hoặc biển thông qua đối thoại trên cơ sở lực pháp khu tế.
Em thấy mông muốn hoặc biển sớm được khu phục lại ở khu cơm.
Về hấp tác ký tế, thủ đường đến nghĩa hai bên tiếp tục tăng cơm hấp tác thông qua biển đường,
nhăng tính độ đàn phán, chế à, giữa Việt Nam, và hội đồng hấp tác mua vệnh gơ sế xe.
Tăng cường kết nối mạnh mẽ hơn nữa giữa văn gơ phán nước,
hủ đường cũng đề gỳ về phía cua đ,
cùng hợp tác chất chế cho vấn đề vào đam anh đi ngang lượng,
nhằm bứng phó với những thách thư diện này,
có phần ổn định sản xuất nổi sống người dân.
Đại sử cua chứa xe xe,
khu bương và lãnh đạo cua đánh ra cao chuyện thầm chính thức của thủ tưởng phạm miến chính tới cua tháng 15 năm,
hành hiểu của trong hay lâm,
và đặc biệt là việc hai nước, nừng các quan hệ lên đối tác chính lực,
tà mừng bước chuyện quan trọng trong quan hệ hệ nước,
trong buổi cạnh hiện nay,
tại sử cho biết cua đá và sẽ hợp tác chất xế với Việt Nam để bảo đam anh đi ngang lượng,
đồng thời khẩn địa chính phủ cua đăng lộ lực cùng các giữa hỗ trợ cần thiết trong người dân cua
và người dân nước ngoài đăng kưu trủ tại cua đỏ có các thủ dân Việt Nam.
Tại sửa công thiết lộ lực,
tích cửc làm cố nối quyền thiết các thầm đoán năng lượng và quy đồ tưu của cua đe
tăng kường giận dịnh tại Việt Nam,
có phần đối quan hệ đối tác chính lực giải nước phát triển ngày hân thứ chất,
biệu quả và tí cầy.